i built a fully functional trainable
analog neural network in minecraft with
no command blocks and no mods
check this out
hello hello
hi hi i'm trying to build a neural net
hi i'm trying to build a neural network
can you
please i don't want to buy your stuff
i'd
like no i don't want a bucket of no i
don't want a bucket of puffer fish
what you're seeing here is an analog
neural network
while lots of people build binary
computers in minecraft
this neural network works in an analog
fashion it means it works directly with
the signal strength
on these wires right here it has two
layers and it has two neurons in its
hidden layer
it computes an output it compares that
output against a target
it back propagates the error back
through the network and it is even able
to
update its own weights in response so
it can fully autonomously learn
any function that you want so today i'm
going to show you
how i built this how it works and what
could potentially be improved
be sure to like this video and let me
know what you think in the comments
so the output is 9 and now i change the
input back to the last data point
the max operation is actually released
yes but the org max isn't
right 86
it learned two data points
he learned two day at the point
so this whole network runs on redstone
redstone is a concept in minecraft
that is a little bit like electricity
you can see right here the torch emits a
signal
and it is transmitted across these wires
in red
right here now the property of redstone
is that it starts out with a signal
strength of 15
as you can see indicated by these lights
and for each distance that it travels
it drops by one signal strength now most
people
simply use the on or off state of these
wires
as binary signals and build computer out
of that
however i decided i wanted to use the
signal strength
directly as a signal and build a neural
network based on that
this gives us a much more compact neural
network and it is much more akin
to how we build neural networks in
machine learning and also
in the brain
next i'm going to show you the main
components that we use to build this
neural network
this here is a lectern and the building
block right behind it is called a
comparator
now the comparator has the ability to
read signal
from blocks before it in this case it
reads the page of the book
that is on the lectern here 9 and
translates that into a redstone signal
you can see the redstone signal is 9
strong at the beginning
and decays with each distance traveled
paradors are actually a special block
in redstone in that they can transmit a
signal without it losing its strength
over distance
in this demonstration you can see the
difference between a comparator and what
is known as a repeater
the comparator simply transmits the
signal one block
and keeps its strength while the
repeater will fully power up the signal
back up to 15
no matter what signal comes in only when
a signal of
zero comes in is the repeater fully off
another interesting fact about
comparators
is the fact that they can be used for
doing math in particular they can do
subtraction here we subtract the side
signal from the main signal
which results in a resulting signal of
strength 2.
note that this comparator is in
subtraction mode because its front light
lights up
this neat thing right here is a divider
it divides the signal
by 4 which is pretty cool since redstone
signal is capped at 0 at the lower end
and 15 at the higher end we don't really
have a lot to work with
dividing by 4 is often useful to bring
the signal back to a manageable
range so this would bring the signal
from 0 to 15 to a range of
0 to 3 or one to four however
we want it the most important building
block in our neural network is going to
be what's
known as a memory cell this is a memory
cell it consists of two comparators each
feeding into a block
and each block powering a cable that
then feds into the comparator again
this is a closed loop and it will save
any state that you give it
i can fully charge it with this button
and i can fully decharge it with this
button
a slight variation on the memory cell is
the decaying memory cell
which i think is pretty cool it is
almost like a memory cell
but since this wire here is of length
two it decharges by one
every time the signal goes around the
cycle so if i fully charge it
what you're going to see is that it
slowly decays over
time let me show that again
[Music]
this is pretty cool this is a multiplier
it is a device that can multiply
two analog signals and it is really cool
how that works it combines the memory
cell and the decaying memory cell
to achieve this multiplication again the
multiplication
is in analog here and not in binary the
design is from a youtube channel called
rkf vaulter and i didn't come up with
this myself and it took me quite a while
to understand what was going on
though once i had it i was able to build
the rest of the neural network
almost without a problem at the bottom
you'll find
a single memory cell that stores 15
minus
whatever we want as an output this
signal is then fed into this comparator
which is in subtraction mode and feeds
from this hopper that is full
so the output is going to be here on top
of the memory cell you'll find a
decaying memory cell the decaying memory
cell
powers this piston here and it is fed
via ultra short tick of this piston
with this signal this is one of our two
input signals
as long as the decaying memory cell is
active this piston
stays down as long as this piston is
down
our second input is fed through this
circuit
into the memory cell at the bottom and
is subtracted that means
the bottom signal is subtracted from
this memory cell
an amount of times that is proportional
to how long the piston stays down
this as you can see results in a
multiplication of the two analog signals
pretty cool here i use this to multiply
the two numbers
two and three as you can see by the
pages of the book
as soon as i hit the button the memory
cell is reset and ultra short pulse is
generated
and this piston stays down just long
enough for the
decharge to happen an appropriate amount
of times you can see the result is
6 and if i change this to a larger
number
say 5 you can see that the piston now
stays down for much longer than before
of course we can only handle signals up
to 15 even with this contraction
the last thing we need is gradient
descent by combining
a multiplier and a memory cell together
with
two pistons that update the memory cell
we can achieve
gradient descent this here was my test
application for gradient descent
it is a square root finder and to my
knowledge it is also the first analog
square root finder that is implemented
in minecraft redstone
innovation happening on this channel
every day
so the way it works is that we have a
memory cell
that we can update using either this
piston or this piston
we can update it up or down we feed the
signal from the memory cell
as the first and the second multiplicand
into the multiplier
the two numbers are then multiplied
together and come out here
on this lectern we set a target that we
would like to know the square root of
in this case i want to know the square
root of the number nine
this circuit right here then calculates
an error signal
and tells the contraction down here
whether we need to go
up or down with our memory cell
depending on that
either this piston or this piston is
activated with an ultra short pulse
and we change the memory cell by one or
negative one
if we repeat this cycle eventually we
should converge to the square root
of whatever we input into this lectern
so if i hit the button right here
square is calculated the error is
calculated the memory cell is updated
and you can see
one is our first guess let's hit the
button again and see what happens
we're at two
[Music]
now we're at three if we hit the button
again
we do expect the network to converge so
you can see there was no more update
so now we have converged on three which
is
of course as you know the square root of
nine if we input any other number
then a pure square the network is going
to oscillate
between the two square roots that are
closest in integer
so here two and now it oscillates back
to three
gradient descent in minecraft thank you
the neural network is a bit more
complicated in that
it can not only do gradient descent by
plus one or negative one
it will actually calculate the exact
error signal
that comes back from the front it will
calculate it
through the non-linearity and it even
has adjustable learning rates
all right now let's try it out so in
this neural network
what you do is you use these two books
to set the input signals
for each of the two input dimensions in
this case it's
one and three and you use this book to
set the target value
in this case i've set it to 12. that's a
bit high
let's set that to 6. once i hit this
button
the whole operation starts in full
automatic mode
let's go so what you're going to see is
the signal forward traveling through the
network
through the first layer into the second
layer which you're going to see
right now after that the output is going
to be displayed after a short flicker
on this pole right here now this happens
to be exactly correct it's not always
the case
after this the network flips into back
prop mode at which point the signal is
traveling backward through the second
layer to the first layer
at the end this piston there is going to
hit which is going to implement the
weight
update given by these upper pistons
right now
and after all of that this control
signal travels back
and we start again let me show you a
little bit more clearly
what happens in each step the neural
network we're going to build here
has two input neurons which can be
loaded with a value
of anywhere between 1 to 15.
this is followed by another layer of
neurons two neurons
form the hidden layer of the network and
yet another layer
one neuron forms the output each layer
is a fully connected layer
which means that every neuron in the
layer before
is connected to every neuron in the
layer above
and the same goes for the second layer
each of these layers has a weight
associated with it the back propagation
formulas
tell us how the signal flows forward in
the network
and also how the signal flows backward
while the optimizer formula
is telling us how we need to update the
weight once we have computed the back
propagation signal
all of this is going to be implemented
in redstone
here you see an overhead diagram of the
neural network in minecraft
i've removed the top layers of the
weights and the weight update mechanisms
otherwise you can see anything
the basic components of each of the
weights are implemented in the
multipliers you can see right here four
weights
four multipliers each multiplier is
followed by a division
by four which is a square thing right
here you can also clearly see
the two hidden neurons here and here
where the non-linearity happens and the
two weights
in the second layer are also implemented
by these two multipliers
the output neuron is implemented at the
back together with the output
signal for the back propagation we have
the two additional multipliers
here and here to calculate the backprop
signal
to the first layer on the bottom you can
see the timing signal to set the network
into backprop mode
so the first thing that happens is this
first row of multipliers
there are four multipliers here as you
can see there's one
there's two there's three and there's
four
the four multipliers represent the four
connections
from the input layer to the hidden layer
since each of the two input neurons
needs to be connected
to each of the two hidden neurons the
connections
have the multiplier to do the actual
multiplication
and the weight of the connection is
stored in a memory cell
above which you can see right here this
memory cell
probably has a weight of about eight
right now
each memory cell is also accompanied by
two pistons
one to add to it and one to subtract
from it
note that other than in the square root
finder here
we don't just add and subtract one
statically
but we actually compute the exact back
prop signal
that we need to add or subtract though i
have implemented a limiting mechanism
for the update which you can set in
these books right
here in this case i've set it to 2 for
this weight
to not have it update too rapidly you'll
also notice that each of these update
pistons
is accompanied by another piston
mechanism this is for generating an
ultra short pulse which is necessary for
us not to
update too much you'll be able to see
the ultrashort pulse in just a second
watch the repeater as the piston moves
up again
did you see that all too short pulse i
think it's known as
a two tick or a three tick pulse as a
one tick pulse will actually
have that piston expel its block and not
retract it again
so after the first row of multipliers
each signal
goes through a circuit like this where
it is divided by
four this is done because again
we work in the range of 0 to 15 which is
not a whole lot
and we've already multiplied two numbers
so dividing the signal by 4 seems like a
reasonable choice
after we divide the sigma by 4 it goes
into the non-linearity here conveniently
labeled with a sine unlike
almost everything else in the entire
network
the non-linearity is a relu
non-linearity though it is not
set at 0 to cut off it is set at 4.
we don't have negative signals in this
game so we'll have to work with what we
get
one thing i implemented is that i do add
one to whatever comes out of the
non-linearity to never have a zero
signal
and therefore never have a zero gradient
for the later weights feel free to
change that though
i have no clue if it works following the
two non-linearities the
second row of weights is coming there's
just two weights here since there's just
one
output neuron there is one multiplier
and there is one multiplier
again the weights are implemented by
memory cells above with update
mechanisms to add
and subtract prepended by ultra short
pulse generators
and again you can adjust the learning
rate using these leg turns
once the output arrives it is stored in
this memory cell right here
and displayed in the column of lights
now that's where the interesting part
only begins
the target value comes in through this
current right here
and is compared to the output value of
the network
here's where we calculate the error we
need to calculate it once into the
positive direction
and once into the negative direction and
we need to remember
whether or not our signal was too high
or too low
two control lines signal for this one
goes underneath here
which is the negative line and one goes
over top there which is the positive
line
once the error is calculated the network
switches into back prop mode
backprop mode is controlled by a timer
mechanism
which is composed of multiple stacked
decaying memory cells
you'll see that this generates a really
long
pulse which controls for how long the
network is in back prop mode
you can see it decaying very slowly one
cell
after the other once all cells are
decayed the network is switched back
into
forward prop mode now what happens in
this back prop mode
in backdrop mode two things happen first
of all
the network is configured to switch the
multipliers here to instead of doing
forward propagation
do back propagation the backdrop formula
tells us that we have to multiply the
error
signal with the input signal to get the
weight updates
rather than implement separate
multipliers for this multiplication
i decided to implement a routing
mechanism that simply detects whether or
not the network is in forward or in back
prop mode
and uses the appropriate inputs into the
same multipliers
the result of the multipliers is then
used as an update signal for the weights
in order to do back propagation through
a neural network you also need to back
propagate the error signal back to the
first layer
for that we need two extra multipliers
which i've implemented one
here this multiplier implements the back
prop signal
for the lower layer including the
gradient of the non-linearity
and the division by 4 that we did in the
forward propagation
it's important but once we're done this
really gives us
the exact back prop signal for the first
layer
and again we reuse the multipliers in
the first layer
and reroute the inputs to calculate the
update signal
during the backprop phase once backprop
is done
a simple control signal instructs all
the weights to update at once
you'll see it when this piston goes up
and the control signal instructs all the
piston in the top layers to fire
and update the weights and that's it
that is one cycle through the network
now by mere
accident we have actually hit the
correct
output from the get-go and thus nothing
is updated
let's try to overfit to one data point
once more
so i've now switched the inputs to 3 and
1.
i'm going to set my target to 12.
let's see what happens and follow along
once more the input goes through
the first row of multiplier hits signal
travels backwards
the second row of multipliers hit after
that
the output is displayed
it is six right now still but that's
going to change
the network is switching into back prop
mode indicated by the flashing up
there you can see the multipliers in the
second row hit
after which the multipliers in the first
row hit
and now the weights are instructed to
update up top
there we go good job once that's done
the control signal travels back and we
go again
first row of multipliers travel back
second row of multipliers
but signal is stored in this memory cell
and displayed right there we're at 9.
network is flipped into backprop mode
these multipliers hit including the
multiplier for the backdrop signal
first row of multipliers hit
and the weights are instructed to update
wait update
there we go good job let's try that one
more time
over prop first row
forward prop second row
[Music]
output is saved and displayed
beautiful and that is an output of 12
for you
this was certainly a challenge it
started as an april fool's joke
and it turned out to be a lot of work
but also fun and the live stream chat
while i was building it was
certainly super helpful and fun to watch
i kind of knew how to do the forward
propagation once i had the multiplier
figured out
but other than that i had no idea what i
was doing
so i will put these worlds on github
for you to mess around with and you can
submit a pull request
if you think you have a substantial
improvement or maybe you'll even find a
bug
it's quite probable honestly so in
conclusion
we used a bunch of weird mechanics of
minecraft to build
the first analog forward propagating
back propagating weight updating
gradient dissenting
non-linearitizing deep neural network
in minecraft it was a pleasure thank you
so much for watching
and i'll see you next time bye bye
you